-Eddie, part of being a legend
means that you spend some time
with other legends, and I was
thinking that I could say
maybe the name of another iconic
person and you can tell me
the first memory or story
that comes to your mind.
Is that okay?
-Yeah, sure, yeah.
I don't know how many legends
I've met.
-I have 104 listed here.
-You have 104 actual legends?
-No, no, no, I only have
like five legends.
Alright. Here we go.
Richard Pryor.
-He was so nice and sweet to me,
and I loved to make him laugh.
There was nothing more rewarding
than to say something
and have Richard Pryor --
[ Laughs as Pryor ]
That's how he laughed.
When Richard did that,
you would be like...
To make Richard laugh? Yeah.
-Right?
-He was so, so, so sweet to me.
-How about Rodney Dangerfield?
-Rodney Dangerfield --
I met him when I was young.
He gave me, like, bad advice.
I met him when I was like 17.
I was 17. I played the Comic
Strip down in Fort Lauderdale,
and Rodney Dangerfield came in
and bumped everybody.
It was like,
"Dangerfield's going up."
And all the comics are like,
"Dangerfield!"
He went up and did...
[ As Dangerfield ]
Yeah, no, I tell you --
[ Normal voice ]
And all that stuff he was doing.
And I was like,
"Mr. Dangerfield, please,"
after he came off and he killed.
I said, "Please watch my show."
I wanted to go up after him,
right,
'cause I thought
I was a hot shot.
I went up there
and I crushed it.
And I came off
and Dangerfield's like...
[ As Dangerfield ]
Yeah, you know, you use a lot of
foul language
and you say [bleep].
You use that language.
Where are you gonna go
talking that kind of stuff?
[ Normal voice ]
He gave me all this stuff.
Like, all the wind
came out of my sails.
I was like, "Ugh, Dangerfield."
Then, you know,
three years went by.
I get on "Saturday Night Live,"
and three years go by.
I'm at Caesar's Palace in
Las Vegas, and I'm at a urinal.
And Dangerfield walks in,
and he comes in the urinal
right next to me.
And I look over and he looks
over at me and says...
[ As Dangerfield ]
"Hey, who knew?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] That's
my Rodney Dangerfield story.
-At least he was funny.
-He was totally real with it.
He was totally funny with it.
-[ As Dangerfield ]
Hey, who knew, huh?
Hey, who knew?
-[ Normal voice ] My favorite
Rodney joke, he goes,
"My wife's cooking is so bad.
Are you kidding me?
I mean, since when does
toast have bones?"
-[ as Dangerfield ] You know?
Since when does toast
have bones, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-I went to my dentist.
He told me my teeth are yellow.
He told me wear a brown necktie.
You know what I mean?
[ Normal voice ]
So to have that guy tell you,
"I don't think
you have a future, kid,"
I was like, "What the [bleep]?"
-Heartbreaking.
-I was crestfallen.
But he kept it real.
-"Hey, who knew?"
is unbelievable.
That's perfect.
-"Hey, who knew?"
It was like the perfectly timed
three-year gap.
Three-year buildup
to that moment.
And right, you look over,
he's right there.
"Hey, who knew?" Perfect.
-Good line.
Muhammad Ali.
-Oh, Muhammad Ali is my hero.
That's my hero.
-I remember you --
You did Ali, didn't you?
-Yeah, I've done impressions
of him,
but there's not another person
that inspired me
more in life than Muhammad Ali.
I think he's the greatest
African-American
that ever lived,
that ever walked the Earth.
Like, no one had the impact
like Muhammad Ali.
-And you got to hang out
with him?
-Oh, I didn't get to hang out
with him.
I met him a couple of times.
-Oh.
-I met him a few times.
And he gave me
a really cool thing.
For my 40th birthday, he gave me
a plaque with a glove on it.
It was like, "From your brother
Muhammad Ali."
My most treasured thing is this
cool little plaque from Ali.
-Gosh.
Do you remember
that Ed Bradley interview he did
on "60 Minutes,"
him and Ed Bradley?
It was later, as he --
-Oh, after, yeah, when he
pretended he was sleeping?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
And then he acted like
he was having fits.
Yeah, it was very funny.
-He's, like, punching.
-And that's one of the things
that was beautiful about Ali,
that he always had --
he was always Ali, even when
his health started to fail.
He was never --
That spirit was still there.
He was always Ali.
-That's so cool.
-I love Muhammad Ali so much.
-Well, Stevie Wonder.
You must have met Stevie Wonder.
You sang with him.
-Yeah, I met Stevie.
Yeah, Stevie's an old friend,
and I love Steve.
And he's a true genius.
Stevie's the genius --
You know how you hear people say
somebody's a genius
or this person's a genius?
Stevie Wonder is a real genius.
If you're around him, it's like,
okay, that's what a genius is.
It's like, okay,
I never seen one before.
And when you see him,
especially if you're around him
and he's doing something with
music, then it's --
then you're really blown away
by it.
But it don't even have to
be that.
Just be around him
and he's just a genius.
-Yeah, it's almost insane
when you get to really see,
like, someone like that
and you're just like --
You go, "Yeah," and notes
just start playing like...
[ Vocalizing ]
-Yeah, I think of all the
artists I've met ever in life,
the two that I've met felt,
like, you know,
this otherworldly amount of
talent and genius
was Stevie and Prince.
They were like,
okay, this is a genius.
-Yeah, and Prince --
We talked a little bit about
Prince last time you were here.
And he was on our show
a bunch of times.
I always tell people
if they ask me about him
that he was actually funny.
He loved to laugh.
-Yeah, yeah, sense of humor,
yeah.
Oh, another genius is McCartney.
-Yeah. Of course.
-I've been around --
Yeah, those three.
You know, those three.
Prince, McCartney, and Stevie.
I was like, "I'm in the presence
of a genius."
-Did the story
that your brother Charlie --
which, again, I'm sorry
to hear about his passing --
the story about Prince
challenging you
to a game of pickup basketball
that he told on "Chappelle,"
I'm sure that really happened,
but --
-That is totally
and absolutely accurate.
-But he gave you outfits?
-No, we had on stuff
from the club, you know.
So we had on club clothes,
and Prince had on that outfit
that was in the "Kiss" video
where he had the little,
like, short shirt
and the leather jacket
with the buttons and stuff.
He had that outfit on
and a little gold chain
around his waist.
A waistlet, I think.
He had on a waistlet.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like, "Yo, want to
play some basketball?"
We was like, "What the [bleep]?
You want to play
some basketball?"
It was like,
"Alright, let's play."
My brother was --
It was Prince and some dude,
a dude named Micki Free
that used to hang out.
They used to all kind of wear
their kind of Prince clothes.
So my brother was like,
"Alright, it's gonna be
shirts against blouses."
[ Laughter ]
-And who won?
-And they teamed up
and the blouses won.
They beat the [bleep] out of us.
But you know what I think?
We had one dude on our squad
that could play named Larry,
and he didn't have no shoes,
so Prince said --
gave him some sneakers, right?
And Prince wore, like,
maybe two, three sizes
smaller than Larry,
but Larry was so excited
to have Prince's sneakers on,
he put them tiny sneakers
on his feet,
so he couldn't do his game.
-Toes all crammed up.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so he couldn't execute.
So we lost.
The one dude that could play,
Prince's shoes had him shut
down, so he couldn't execute.
-That's genius!
That's the genius move.
Eddie, I always love
talking to you.
I'm so happy.
Congrats on everything.
Congrats on "Coming 2 America."
I can't wait for the world
to see it.
It's gonna stream on
Amazon Prime Video
beginning next Friday.
Thanks again for coming by.
Come whenever.
-Yeah, man, I'm gonna come by.
I can't wait to come by
when it's all safe to come.
-Yep. Oh, you're always welcome.
-Yeah, man.
-Thank you so much. Congrats.